los opioides son medicamentos que se
recetan para tratar el dolor moderado o
intenso el fentanilo es un potente
opioide sintético puede recetarse para
tratar el dolor intenso provocado por el
cáncer o una cirugía es hasta 50 veces
más potente que la heroína un opioide
ilegal y 100 veces más potente que la
morfina otro opioide usado para tratar
el dolor intenso
para entender Cómo funcionan los
opioides como el fentanilo Es importante
saber cómo el organismo siente el dolor
el proceso comienza cuando algo dañino
ocurre en su organismo la información
sobre este daño se convierte en una
señal nerviosa la señal pasa por los
nervios hasta la médula espinal y llega
al
cerebro en su cerebro la señal se
percibe como dolor el fentanilo afecta
la forma de sentir el dolor se adhiere a
estructuras llamadas receptores o
estos receptores se encuentran en las
células del cerebro en la médula espinal
y en otras zonas del cuerpo el fentanilo
actúa sobre estos receptores Para que
sienta menos el
dolor el fentanilo también puede tener
otros efectos en el
organismo puede provocarle un subidón
intenso de corta duración y sentimientos
de extrema
felicidad el fentanilo también activa la
vía de recompensa en el cerebro Esto
hace que ciertas partes de la vía de
recompensa liberen una sustancia química
llamada dopamina los científicos creen
que la dopamina le ayuda a recordar lo
bien que se sentía mientras tomaba
fentanilo y hace que quiera seguir
tomándolo este vínculo entre recordar
cosas que le hacen sentir bien y el
deseo de volver a hacerlas es una parte
importante del desarrollo de la
adicción el fentanilo también puede
ralentizar su
respiración y hacerle sentir náuseas
además puede reducir el movimiento
intestinal lo que causa estreñi
hay dos tipos de fentanilo la forma
farmacéutica y la forma ilícita o ilegal
Aunque la forma farmacéutica del
fentanilo puede recetarse para tratar el
dolor intenso puede haber un uso no
recetado como en demasiada cantidad
tomarlo para sentirse colocado o dárselo
a otra
persona la forma ilícita se fabrica y se
vende ilegalmente en el mercado de la
droga la gente la toma porque produce un
fuerte subidón e intensas sensaciones de
bienestar
el fentanilo es un opioide peligroso y
adictivo por su
potencia como con cualquier opioide la
adicción al fentanilo es una enfermedad
neurológica en la que se tiene un deseo
abrumador de consumir el fármaco usted
no puede dejar de tomar el medicamento a
pesar del daño que pueda causarle Si
deja de tomarlo se sentirá mal este
malestar se llama abstinencia los
síntomas de abstinencia del fentanilo
pueden ser graves por lo que muchas
personas no dejan de tomarlo estos
pueden pueden incluir ansiedad dolores
óseos y musculares aumento del ritmo
cardíaco presión arterial alta vómitos y
diarrea sudoración y escalofríos y
problemas de
sueño una sobredosis de fentanilo o
tomar demasiada cantidad de este fármaco
puede provocar síntomas potencialmente
mortales o incluso la muerte dependiendo
del tamaño de su cuerpo y del tiempo que
lleve tomando el fármaco tan solo 2 migr
pueden causarle la
muerte la mayoría de los casos de
sobredosis y muerte por fentanilo en los
Estados Unidos están relacionados con el
consumo de la forma ilícita y como el
fentanilo es potente y barato de
fabricar ilícitamente a menudo se mezcla
con otras drogas ilegales como la
heroína la cocaína y las metanfetaminas
esto es peligroso porque una persona
puede tomarla sin querer lo que puede
provocarle una sobredosis accidental o
la
muerte
los síntomas de la sobredosis de
fentanilo pueden incluir confusión
pupilas contraídas o puntiformes
sensación de somnolencia o pérdida de
conocimiento respiración débil lenta o
detenida la incapacidad para hablar
cuerpo inerte piel fría y húmeda con
labios y uñas
descoloridos ritmo cardíaco lento o
detenido y la
muerte según los centros para el control
y prevención de enfermedades más de 150
estad unidenses mueren a diario por
sobredosis de opioides incluido el
fentanilo si tiene preguntas sobre el
fentanilo o si usted o alguien cercano a
usted necesita ayuda para tratar el
consumo de opioides hable con su
médico para más fuentes de información u
otros lugares donde recibir ayuda
consulte los enlaces en la descripción a
continuación
i